and now last year's nominee for Best
Supporting Actress for the color purple
Miss Oprah Winfrey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I can tell you it is a lot
easier on the nerves being a presenter
than a nominee you can concentrate on
watching the show instead of spending
three hours making your deals with God
promising to go on a diet to go to
church stop biting your nails stay out
of shopping malls and everything in
between
well the one word you hear over and over
among filmmakers is passion I like that
word passion and nowhere is that passion
more evident than in the work of the
documentary filmmakers with small
budgets skeleton crews and minimal
chances for commercial success they
transform their deepest passions into a
cinematic art form that will send their
message out to the entire world the
following filmmakers have achieved their
passion the nominees for achievement and
doc you marry features are Artie Shaw
time is all you've got
Bridget Berman producer
[Applause]
[Music]
jillaine hasta cuando David Bradbury
producer down and out in America
Joseph fury and Milton Justice producers
[Music]
Isaac in America a journey with Isaac
Bashevis singer Kirk Simon and Imran
Noah produces witness to apartheid
Sharon isoka producer and the winner is
it is a tie a tie the winners are Artie
Shaw time is all you've got
Bridget Berman producer and down and out
in America Joe secure a and Milton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much members of Academy
for this great honor and thank you
already for trusting me with your life
story and for so many years of just such
incredible inspiring music they a lot of
people I'd like to thank my sort-of
producer Don Haig without whom I'd never
could have made the film and especially
please is it's a Canadian film about a
great American artist that has been
honored this way thank you everybody who
helped me the Canada Council the Ontario
Arts Council Nick Laidlaw telefilm
Canada just everybody who worked on it
thank you very very much
[Music]
I've got a lot of people to thank but
time is running short so thank Michael
Fuchs
sis Wilson verge of poverty navigator
and all our friends at HBO my first
partner saw Brandon my friends rich is
that Nina never b-tree and my mother
Rachel who a lot of you know thank you
very much we'd also like to thank our
crew and our staff through Greenblat Tom
Hurwitz Milton Ginsberg Carol Cuddy
Tommy Manoff and our director Lee grant
whose passion and persistence and anger
made this film possible this is for the
people who are still down and out in
America
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys my next trick presenter is a
three-time nominee the brilliant star of
jagged edge and a nominee tonight for
Best Actress and Aliens ladies and
gentlemen with Sigourney Weaver and mr.
Jeff Bridges
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]